Let's go to our caller from the 9 0 6 area
code who's calling today from 9 06.
9 0 6, are you there, maybe you have this
muted.
Last opportunity for 9 0 6.
And 9 0 6 is gone.
Let's try instead the 9 1 4.
Who's calling today from 9 1 4?
Deb in West Chester, New York, how are you?
I've been better.
You know, I was somebody who by then was not
my first choice.
In fact, he was my last choice, right.
Of all of all the opportunities of people
to go with.
But I'm sorry.
I just don't see how anything matters anymore
at this point with what we're going through.
I think where I am now, I'm about 40 minutes
north of New Rochelle.
OK.
So we're pretty close to the epicenter of
one of the largest breakouts in the United
States.
Yeah.
And I just can't see how anything else with
somebody who.
You know, as a family, I have a seven year
old son now who is the entire world is flipped
upside down.
And you have to think about the world that
we're leaving our kids where they have lockdown
drills and now there's going to be probably
virus procedures that go through.
It's just it's just really, really sad.
And I know that, you know, Bernie Sanders
is the more ideal candidate for a good amount
of your viewers and listeners and and myself
as well.
But the guy in charge right now sucks so bad.
And he's such a monster.
Yeah.
This to this country and to the world that
it can't I can't even imagine how anybody
who is remotely a liberal or a Democrat or
a progressive, how would you even thought
in your mind?
Like you have to put your whole effort into
Biden at this point.
Yeah.
It's a sad reality.
I'm so I'm very emotional.
I get you know, I hear you.
And this.
Listen, this is we're all going to remember,
you know, life before this virus thing and
life after.
And it's going to change a lot of things for
a lot of people.
Not everybody's going to make it just mathematically.
That's the reality.
And one of the things I'm noticing is that
faced with the virus, things like the primaries
and arguing about Bernie versus Biden and
stuff like that, it's becoming very back seat
for a lot of people.
And the thing is, I get it.
But we also don't want to lose the sort of
the thread, the plot, which is we've got to
get Trump out because it's hard to imagine
a worse person.
And yet it's hard to do electoral politics
when we're trying to figure out how can we
stop the transmission of this virus.
Absolutely.
And again, I'm the person I'm the kind of
person that thinks that Bernie Sanders is
a thousand percent on the money when it comes
to health care.
Right.
And a lot of his other ideas, I think, are
exactly where we need to go.
But, you know, this is such a unfortunate
in life or death situation.
Yes.
That this is this is the threat that people
were talking about.
You know, it's the threat that we've been
talking about with with with the changing
environment, with climate change, that that's
going to eventually affect us in the next
few years.
And we're going to have these similar conversations
about, you know, why didn't we make the necessary
changes when we could write the kinds of the
kind of drastic changes that we're doing now
with hunkering down.
Is the same kind of things we need to do with
climate change.
And that isn't going to happen with this with
this guy in charge at all.
Right.
And it's not going to happen with these with
these Republicans in power either, that they're
just dishonest ghouls.
And we need to all come together and realize
that we're we're leaving a hole for our our
kids to grow up in an environment where we
either, you know, had to swallow the choice
of going with a guy that is not our ideal
candidate.
We do not agree with them on the majority
of issues with what we can agree with, that
he is not Trump.
Right.
And he will do maybe something different.
Yeah.
This this is not a drill.
It's become very real very quickly, I think
is the point you're making very lucidly.
Dan, I appreciate the call and stay safe up
there in in Westchester.
Thank you very much.
And keep up the good work.
All right.
Great to hear from you.
That does do it for calls today.
I know a lot of people wanted wanted to get
on.
We have 35 people holding, but we did what
we could.
We will take a break and we will speak to
you very, very soon.
If you weren't able to get on